time is our most valuable resource and
in many professions
it is critically important to manage it
properly
data science is no exception to that so
keep watching and i'm going to share
with you all
how i manage my time i'm richard and
this is richard undata
so in data science it is common that you
either have a lot of responsibility
or you're functioning in sort of a
generalist capacity
meaning you're involved in a ton of
different projects and because you have
to run around between different
responsibilities all the time
it can really be difficult to get things
done and that's before we get into the
worst distractors of
all which are emails and meetings
now at the end of the day working your
40 hours or whatever
is not what's going to bring economic
value to your company
it's what you're able to accomplish in
the time that you're working
and most companies are going to be
fairly flexible with you
they're going to allow you to manage
your own time so it is on you
to do that well there's this talk of
work-life balance or as jeff bezos calls
it
work-life harmony to consider as well so
if you go way too hard at your work
whether that's in data science or
anything else you are going to find that
other aspects of your life
suffer now i want to take a step back
from all that and just speak personally
on this
in the sense that i work a 40 hour per
week regular job as a data scientist
i'm a landlord and i also make youtube
videos on a fairly consistent schedule
then all that's on top of trying to
maintain a relationship
a healthy life and also possibly
entertaining
other entrepreneurial efforts in the
future so
if in the time that i'm working i'm not
productive
or i'm not working under some kind of
discipline structure
i am going to get destroyed in some way
now i'm not saying that i have a perfect
system by any stretch of the imagination
but what i do does enable me to get
things done
and clearly see what i've gotten done
day after day and week after week
before we get into that i would ask
though to subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and hit the notification
bell
let's get to 5 000 subscribers by the
end of the year
and then smash the like button because
it really does help my content reach a
larger audience
lastly if you guys would be willing to
support me over on patreon
there's going to be a link to that in
the description and it would be
enormously appreciated
all right so before we step over to my
whiteboard and really see what i have
i'm going to start with some overall
principles the most important of which
is
you need to know yourself most
importantly
you need to know what the most
productive time of day is for you
then you need to line up all the tasks
that you have in front of you
and you need to identify what the
highest priority or most important item
is
and you need to do that item when you
are most productive
for me personally i'm most productive in
either the late morning or the early
afternoon
in fact i'm a huge fan of blocking time
off on my calendar
let's call that focus time and then
using that time
to focus on the most important things to
me having said that
and i know a lot of people are different
from me in this respect
but i do get benefit off of what i like
to call a snowball effect
meaning if there are a bunch of little
things that i need to do
sometimes i feel a big sense of
accomplishment from
doing these things checking them off the
list and then when it comes
time to do what's most important to me
it's done
it's off my radar and i don't have to be
distracted by it or think about it
for that reason and again i know a lot
of people hate them
but i am a huge fan of to-do lists
there's nothing that gives me a worse or
more anxious feeling
than looking back at the end of the day
and feeling like i got
nothing done and when i check meaningful
items off of a list
it really does give me a big dopamine
rush and it gives me this sense of
satisfaction that i just want to keep
going
i think writing down what you need to do
is super important because if there's a
lot on your plate
it's just natural that stuff ends up
slipping through the cracks
but the to-do list is not enough by
itself you need
prioritization and you need some
additional structure
just the to-do list by itself is not
going to be enough
and i'm also a huge believer in doing
one thing at a time
because if you're trying to multitask
and context shift all over the place
it's just a recipe for disaster but
that's enough
without further ado come over to my
whiteboard with me
oh there you are good to see you again i
thought i'd lost you
so the first thing you'll notice is that
i have four distinct sections here
and those are work youtube health
and miscellaneous where the
miscellaneous bucket consists of things
like relationship related things
errands work on my house just general
stuff like that
but what's great about having sections
like this is
in and of itself it helps keep these
different areas in balance
like if several days go by and i haven't
checked anything off the health list
well that's a big problem now i like to
pick a time
frame for this of about three to four
days
reason being one day is too short of a
window to really think about
but it is a lot more difficult to
accurately estimate what you can and
cannot get done
within a period of one week you'll see
up here that i have a period that i'm
looking at
of november 30 through december 2nd
which is monday through wednesday of the
coming week in which i'm recording this
video
so let's start up here at the upper left
section of the board
and these are the tasks that i have to
do for my day job
so you'll notice that the first item
that i have on this list
is provide email feedback about sops
this is just one of those email related
tasks that i have to do
it's probably going to take me somewhere
around 20 minutes
and this is probably the very first
thing that i'm going to do when i start
work on monday
reason being first thing in the morning
especially on mondays
is not exactly my most useful time of
day
so if i get started and just knock that
thing out
i have one less thing that i have to
worry about during the week
now the next item on this list is make
requested fixes to a shiny app
let's suppose i sent some shiny app over
to a client
then they bounced it back to me they
have some requests for some changes or
some improvements that i can make
well you'll also notice that i have a
star next to it
and that's because i've identified that
this item
is the single most important thing that
i have to do in the work
category so sometime in the late morning
or the early afternoon
i am going to block some time off let's
say two to three hours
and i'm going to focus solely on this
task
i estimate that it's probably gonna take
me somewhere around three to four hours
and during my most productive time of
day this is the thing that i'm going to
focus on
i also have under that create a new
shiny module
let's say another client was talking to
me and they want me to build out either
some little shiny app or a new section
in an app
and i estimate that this is going to
take me somewhere around
eight hours or a full day but it's not
necessarily the most urgent and
important thing on my calendar right now
so probably let's say on tuesday or
wednesday
this task is going to be done it's going
to be checked off
and then on that following day i can put
the star
next to creating this new shiny module
and that can be the new task that i
focus on for that day i have some
training that i need to complete
it comes in four parts that i'm gonna
break down
and that's all gonna fall under training
this is probably stuff that i'm gonna do
maybe later in the week first thing in
the morning or
on any of these days at the very end of
the day when i'm feeling more sleepy and
i'm not necessarily at my most
productive during those times either
now what i'll say is these four tasks
are almost definitely
not going to take me the full 24 hours
or the entire period of the three days
and i do this very intentionally just
because
in this line of work for me anyway stuff
can fall on my plate occasionally
like something will come up that i have
to do and then maybe on tuesday or
wednesday when that happens
maybe it's something that i can knock
out in a day and then i'll add it to the
list
but this way it does make me a little
bit more flexible that i've not
overloaded myself up front as they say
under promise and over deliver so that's
it for my day job
now for a richard on data first i'm
going to take you backstage to where i
plan
out my full week for youtube content
which is of course
right here i try to make two videos per
week
one of which is some kind of programming
tutorial and one of which is a video
like this one
where i'm going on about some topic but
you generally see me on camera the
entire time
and these videos in which i'm on camera
the entire time
take much more time than the programming
tutorials
just because for structural purposes i
do rely
fairly heavily on a script creating that
script is hands down
the most challenging and the most
time-consuming but also probably the
most
important part of the work that i do
with youtube
so as a result i do have a star next to
scripting my on-camera video
and typically what i'll do is i block
off tuesday evenings for getting these
things done
as for the other items on this list i've
got scripting vr
tutorial that you're going to see next
week filming vr
tutorial that i wrote last week but that
you're going to see
this week and then there are other
things that i have to do
like creating a thumbnail editing a
description
tags and just general things like that
that i'm all lumping together under an
umbrella of
editing in our tutorial so hopefully you
get the idea by now
but the next section on this board is my
health and yes this is important enough
that it does get its own quadrant
so the single most important thing there
is working out
i do your standard three days at the gym
routine of
back legs and chest and again this is
the most important thing
so i have the back day start here that's
probably something that i'll do on
monday with the leg day coming on
wednesday
and these are typically what i'll do
like first thing in the morning
or immediately when i'm done with work i
also take a pretty strong regimen of
vitamins and supplements
but i gotta be totally honest i'm the
absolute worst at actually remembering
to take them
so if i put this on the list number one
i actually remember to take them
but then also these really are the
easiest and quickest things in the world
to check off the list
i also like to go for walks during the
day just to burn some additional
calories
i'd like to do that twice during this
three day period so i've got two boxes
to check for walking
then for my miscellaneous section over
here the most important thing is buying
a christmas present for my girlfriend
i'm not going to say what that is
because she watches my videos
i've got meal prep i've got cleaning my
garage
and now for this one my garage is an
absolute abomination
but this is one of those things that
it's really not important enough that i
need to give it more than 30
minutes so i'm going to time box it to
30 minutes and that's it
and then i've got creating a budget for
the month of december
so now you get the idea of how i stay
productive
at my data science job produce regular
content for my youtube channel
and at the same time balance other
aspects of my life
but i will add a few things to this
first of all
you do need to know what's most
important to you both at work
and in your overall life otherwise
whether you adopt a system like this or
not
you are going to struggle with what
aspects of your life to even balance
with
others and you're going to struggle
figuring out what to do
in order to be productive rather than
just busy which is a different thing
my friend and fellow youtuber kenji
recommended a book
called one thing to me at one point and
i must say
is probably the best book on time
management i've ever read
the key question from that book is to
think about what the one
thing that you can do day after day is
that's going to make
other things unnecessary or easier you
block off time
and you focus hard on that thing day
after day
but you also do it with a longer term
horizon several years down the road
thinking backwards i'll have a link to
that book in the description
and then another one that i really like
which is an absolute classic
is seven habits of highly effective
people by stephen covey
his key piece of advice is to focus your
time on what's not
urgent but is important because that's
exactly the type of stuff that tends to
slip through the cracks most
meanwhile for stuff that's urgent but
not important
delegate or say no to it and just start
saying no to those things which are
neither urgent nor important
at the end of the day i think whatever
system that you choose to use
is totally up to you but i would
advocate to anybody who's in the data
science
or just generally any other type of
entrepreneurial space
your money can be replaced that is
you're gonna spend your money and then
you're gonna get some back
your time is not like that once you lose
it it's gone forever
so manage it like it is your most
important resource
because that's exactly what it is so
thanks for watching this video
if you enjoyed it smash the like button
and drop me a comment down below
and let me know how you manage your time
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then richard on data